I was a kid I would literally have pus
oozing out of my face I would wake up in
the morning stuck to my own pillow like
it was off I mean my skin I looked like
a hot dog that was run over by a car it
was just brutal a painful uncomfortable
so I'm no stranger to health issues and
my body it always goes to the extreme it
always like if and so I was like oh it's
gonna be stage four there's no way my
body wouldn't allow me to get anything
less than a stage four and so part of me
was live stage six
there was not even a five you skipped
right over that into six you're just
hurdling over stages
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Music]